[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody
happy sunday hope your weekend is going
well
yep we're went well it's almost over now
don't say that well it's sunday i know
but you still got like several hours
yeah don't make it seem like oh the
weekend's over already you still got
this
every day is like sunday remember when
sunday meant something that doesn't mean
anything to me it's just another day
well you know like i said sunday when
you had to go back to school when you
were a kid
yeah that's awesome yeah that's like oh
man yeah or when you had to go back to
work
right i used to hate that right like the
longer sunday went on i was just kind of
like no
no stop i don't want to go to work
tomorrow
but you know okay so uh esther says hi
tom and jenny hi esther
how you doing so we're going to talk
about death proof
and we're going to talk well let's talk
about creep choppers creature because
that won't take as long because like i
said that's new when i can't really
spoil it
okay um so let's talk about
shutters creep shift series this is
season two
episode four uh again two stories
now the first one uh it was kind of
short actually it was called pipe
screams
now what was interesting about this one
uh it starred barbara crampton
yeah she still looks great man and she's
just like real well i'm on her instagram
too so like i see pictures of her like
she posts pictures
uh all the time she's pushing 70. and
she's yeah she's in her 60s and it's
like she looks
fantastic mid 60s you would never know
you wouldn't know she was in her mid 60s
no there's a couple shots
you they show her from certain angles
well i mean you can tell she's not
20. but yeah you know but
mostly she hasn't changed that much not
really
on the face she looked way back in the
re-animator days
yeah but it looks like even her figure
kind of held up
from the clothes you know it's hard to
tell but because man she had a smoking
body and they would show it off too like
from beyond those were a good one yeah
that was a good moment
she's had she's got a little bit of work
done well yeah you would you would think
yeah
probably hormone therapy but [ __ ] you
know she's like it looks great i mean
you know if your teeth fall out you put
teeth back in
you know you wear false teeth same thing
you say that all the time
that's my [ __ ] motto well we don't
have new people joining the show all the
time
if your teeth fall out just put just put
teeth back in
yeah so uh but no she looks great in
there it was it was a pretty good
little episode this one was it was funny
because she was actually she usually
plays
uh good guys but in this one she played
like the villain yeah she plays
and she seemed to be really having a
good i mean she played like the
quintessential karen right she was just
kind of like she had
the [ __ ] uh the the kind of mom can i
see your manager hair
and she had like a [ __ ] thing of
chardonnay and like [ __ ]
she plays the evil she plays the evil
landlord or not
she's like a slum lord she's not really
a landlord is i think she's just super
well she no she owns the bill because
she says in there that she owns some of
the buildings
so i guess like she's kind of a slum
lord she owns all these
you know tenement buildings [ __ ] up
buildings yeah and uh she's
she's super wealthy but she doesn't want
to like pay any money to fix anything
yeah cheat's gate
she yeah so she's you know so uh
so she calls a plumber because all the
pipes are backed up and she finally
can't take any of the complaints anymore
and she makes like a lot of really um
kind of nasty comments about oh all
these
foreigners that live in the building and
their hair is weird and they're all like
clogging the pipes up or whatever so she
calls this uh the plumber
whose name is linus and he comes there
and he goes down to the basement and
sees this building is so [ __ ] old it
has lead pipes and he's like hey
um these are not legal anymore like i'm
gonna have to pull all this [ __ ] out and
put copper pipes and she's like [ __ ]
that i'm not paying for all that kind of
money
yeah and then as it goes on you discover
that
there is indeed something in the pipes
uh and it ain't rats
no it's a hairball monster i think they
called the monster cloggy
yeah i think that's what they nicknamed
it like not not on the show but on the
i mean yeah um i i have to say the
effects
on the cloggy monster were really good
yeah
they're practical effects it's kind of
like the blob
yeah kind of except it's kind of made of
hair and like yucky
drain fat and like other crap that's in
there
comes out and attacks you gets like
different sizes and different pull and
it kills the kitty
pretty also it's kind of like the oil
slick monster i guess out of that
stephen king yeah and some people have
compared that like
because i think that there was a direct
homage to that like near the end where
the hair kind of comes up like tentacles
sort of
around the leg yeah it was like the raft
which was in creep show too like the
movie
it's a good little it's a good little
story it's nothing really special it's
it's basically the same story as the
creep show
classic story from the first movie but
the guy with the roaches
a lot of them are like that well that's
what a lot of the easy comics were like
that because like everybody you know you
always want to see like some [ __ ]
get their comeuppance you know what i
mean and that's kind of what a lot of
the story lines are like
so that's pretty much exactly what this
one it's very very simple like i said
the um it's great seeing barbara
crampton playing that role because she
was really having a good time with it i
think that i think linus actually does
call her a [ __ ] karen at some point
which i thought was very funny
but um you know she comes in with her
[ __ ] chardonnay glass and she's all
like
hammered and whatnot but it was cool
seeing her playing a [ __ ] because she
doesn't usually
but um yeah so that one was good and
then the second one which was kind of
longer the second one
um oh i will i wanted to note too that
pipe screams the first one was actually
the guy that wrote it daniel krauss was
the same guy
that co-wrote that book with george
romero
the living dead that you know that big
tone which like it kind of made up i
haven't read it yet but um i've heard
it's really good
so this second one was uh
a lovecraft story as was essentially a
cthulhu
mythos uh tale and this was uh done by
john harrison it's called within the
walls of madness
and basically it was kind of like there
was this guy and he's
um i guess he's in prison or he's on
death row or
i don't know and like some lawyer is
coming to talk to him and it looks very
much like he has
murdered all of the like a couple people
at this
underground research facility and he's
trying to make the argument
that he didn't really kill them but
that the experiments that they were
working on
um and the actually the one of the
doctors was dr trollenberg played by
denise crosby who was
uh what's her name on the star trek
right
yeah yeah yeah and she was in the
original pet cemetery too
i forgot what that woman's name was she
played what the [ __ ] was that what's the
[ __ ] side character name
goddammit lieutenant you are right yeah
yeah yeah there you go yeah she got
fired for posing in playboy
that's right i remember that yeah we
looked at that issue when that came out
well
it wasn't really much to see
like man they fired her over that
well i mean playboy was like so tame it
just seems like
that's just silly yeah she wasn't really
rocking any kind of [ __ ] you know i
mean she wasn't ugly you know she had a
nice figure but it wasn't like you know
no it wasn't ba no it wasn't bad
you know it wasn't some kind of genetic
anomaly and and
those playboy girls were all genetic
anomalies
they were that wasn't normal and a lot
of that [ __ ] was man-made but that's
okay
beauty is man-made it's just fake beauty
is fake
natural beauty is not wiping your ass
there's something beautiful about that
right now there's another quote for
sure nothing beautiful about being there
about not wiping your ass
nothing beautiful about being there
somebody would just go to a developing
country where they don't have run of
water and [ __ ]
go look for that natural beauty you'll
find it
like get me out of here well you know
mango says mango said barbara crampton
was uh looking hot in this episode yeah
yeah
she's looking hot all the time yeah but
yeah so uh
some people are holding out man they
hold out [ __ ] looking good over the
years
it's not like it was yeah and like i
said her especially because i'm on her
instagram so sometimes like i see like
when she posts pictures like from
various things and i'm just like holy
crap she looks really good it just
doesn't come
easy though you know money it has money
and work
and work and surgery and technology
it's not free but you could have to pay
to look good yeah well because think
about
before we had you know all the surgical
techniques before they had
all the [ __ ] that we have nowadays um
you know old people
you know once you got to like 50 years
old it was a wrap you looked
like a few few hundred miles a bad road
you know
most people did according to the films
of the 1950s you look [ __ ] up at 35.
so you know what sometimes i see some of
those old movies like from the 40s and
50s
and if you asked me to guess like how
old that actor was like when they were
playing that part i'd be like i don't
know 45
50 something like that and then you find
out they're like 28 or so yeah yeah like
that i'm like
oh my goodness hard living
hard living bad food bad diet yes
people don't realize what what they ate
in the 50s
and the 40s and the 30s it was pretty
bad man bunch of crap that's crap
[ __ ] canned food they had no
nutrition every bit of nutrition was
[ __ ] soaked
you know sucked up right out of that
[ __ ] well yeah
i mean [ __ ] i got a little bit of the
tail end of that because particularly in
the south i feel like they still ate
like
there's like yeah let's boil the [ __ ]
out of every single vegetable so there's
no vitamins left
in there like you just throw that broth
out yeah you don't want that
vegetable water
what she's talking about is that when we
were little kids the way your
grandmother and [ __ ] cooked and
out of the way your parents cooked
because they learned it from her that
was all depression era
depression thank you gadgey thank you
very much and and the south was always
in the [ __ ] great depression the
south was in the great depression in the
1850s
with the war so it was always in in a
certain way
[ __ ] kind of you know it was kind of
rough living in certain ways um
if you had your own farm you ate well
but most of you didn't have time for
that
you know i mean unless you were out in
the middle of it you had people that
worked in towns
didn't have time to farm so they ate
canned food food
you know and i'm not in much nutrition
nope not at all when white castle and
mcdonald's showed up that was considered
healthy eating
oh man yeah
healthy fast food mm-hmm yeah
i mean you can eat fast food sometimes
as long as you don't eat it like every
day three times a day it's not gonna
kill you but it's like
well in the modern era it's healthy it's
better honestly i think it's probably
better
yeah it's much better i think the
problem with a lot of food nowadays is
more
the portion size yeah rather than what
is all down french fries all that deep
fried food
well and they give i mean if you go to a
restaurant in the u.s and i even had
people like you know from europe like
comment on this if they came over here
they're like you know the food's good
but it's like they give you enough for
like three people
sometimes it's like we can't eat all
that but um you know well
i can't eat all that and i'm like from
here so a lot of times you kind of take
out
did you read that super chat yeah i said
well okay so uh
yeah thank you gadgie all sorted uh he
was having some uh
thing with his card or whatever uh
actual happy today peddled like a mofo
think this will cover what i've missed
thank you so much that is so
awesome but yeah so uh yeah go on
what what i was gonna say something
about the about about the
fast food today you can live there's
bodybuilders that tried it
for months you could actually build a
good body
with fast food well it depends on what
you get depends on what you get
stay away from them [ __ ] french fries
and stay away from those carbonated
drinks
and because here in the united states
that's all corn syrup
and corn syrup will just put fat on you
bad i mean some of the stuff they have
there isn't really all that bad
no the sandwiches and everything is fine
you know it's drinking water some
you want to stay away from the french
fries it's just it's just carbs and it's
you know
fried and not real good for you you get
some but just a little bit you don't
want a bunch of it
yeah um but yeah so what was i saying so
the second
uh story on the creep show thing was
essentially a cthulhu story because
he's making the argument that um i
didn't kill these people
uh exactly it's just that
trollenberg dr schullenberg played by
denise crosby as who we were talking
about before from
star trek that she had summoned
cthulhu with this weird it was like a
weird like
living whistle type of thing like it
looked it was really cool looking then
like you blew on it and it summoned and
cthulhu is like hey what's up and would
like come in through the walls
and then would like you know grab people
with the tentacles and take them to the
whoring out of the world or whatever
so uh so yeah this was actually good if
you like like um you know
love crafty and [ __ ] this was a pretty
good lovecraftian adaptation some good
gore
in this one uh the cthulhu looked a
little bit cheesy but you know
what are you gonna do um i will say my
favorite part of this i think other than
barbara crampton was the cloggy monster
that looks really good i remember that
one no the the
the monster with the yeah yeah that came
out of the drain yeah
i mean that i call it the hairball
monster the hairball monster yeah
i mean it looked really really good yeah
and it pulled this you know the skin off
like the dude's hand and [ __ ] like that
so it was like really good the goring
that was really good but this was um
this was actually a pretty solid episode
i thought that both the stories were
good
i think i slightly preferred the first
one but the second one was good too so
far
this series is i would say worthy to own
on on blu-ray or dvd
oh definitely came out and tried to sell
it it'd be good to own it
yeah i mean i think that there's you
know there was a couple clunkers in
there but
i mean overall yeah that most of them
are actually like
you know pretty decent yeah even the
qualified zone had some
the original twilight zone had yeah
everything does it's because you're
gonna have like a vast
you know a bunch of different writers
you're going to have you know this one's
actually a little bit more consistent
because
they have different writers but it's
it's from the same pool
even original star trek had some
clunkers splash brain
[Laughter]
but she laughed at spock's brain though
you know i had fun even with the
clunkers you weren't going to take that
[ __ ] seriously it was canopy
yeah you know i mean i i haven't seen
any of them that i
that that were not entertaining yeah
they were all entertaining yeah i
thought they were all entertaining so
it's like even if they're well hey poke
what you doing she's like oh i'm
thinking about going in the closet
all right so um as we said now
we kind of talked about death proof a
little bit on the wednesday night
sidetrack show
um but tom said well you know we got
sent death proof
and so we wanted to do like a more
in-depth kind of what was yeah check
that timer oh yeah yeah okay it was a
time for beeping
what are you doing pokey what are you
doing
so we wanted to do like a more in-depth
uh thing of it because i guess he didn't
so
i didn't get to talk about as much as i
wanted to because he's like well let's
just do it on sunday and so that's what
we're gonna do
so forgive us if we go over a little bit
of the same
material did we determine that sophie
sent us this right
yeah yeah now i will say before we get
too much into it we're gonna do
uh probably do a matinee show tomorrow
um
should we do i know a bunch of people on
saturday were saying they wanted us to
do boogie nights and
if you want us to do boogie nights we
can do that because i just found that
it's on 2b for free
or we can do brimstone and treacle which
we just uh which one of uh which dermot
actually gave me money to buy
yeah and so we have that yeah i got a
good copy of that and we have a good
comment that's a weirdos movie
yeah it's good i mean we'll do it
eventually i'm just asking like one what
one you'd rather see tomorrow brimstone
trico was a was a great
movie star and sting that never really
got a us release
uh so americans don't don't really know
about it if you saw it you almost kind
of saw it by accident
i saw it and i was like what the [ __ ] is
it
wow you know it was just really like
entertaining but it made a really good
play
well i think that's what it started out
again okay yeah and it's
sting plays this i guess he's a demon
some kind of british demon well we'll
get into that one we don't know what
about the show i think it's a demon
of some sort well or an imp or it was a
lot
gremlin i'm gonna say it was a lot
clearer in the play was it okay
yeah all right they made it a little
more more ambiguous for the movie okay
but yeah it did start out as a as a
stage play all right that's all i'm
gonna say
but like i said we might do that one
tomorrow or we might do boogie nights
because like i said boogie nights uh is
on 2b for free i think i just checked
um so we might do that because i know a
bunch of people were asking us to do
that movie as well
so let's talk about death proof yeah now
as i said we talked about it a little
bit on wednesday so
if we repeat some of the [ __ ] sorry
about that but you know
not not always the same people are here
so it's okay
quentin tarantino for me is hit and miss
yeah
he's got hits and he's got misses and to
give you like
the perspective i'm gonna have from my
point of view on this movie
once upon a time in hollywood i'd say it
was a hit
pulp fiction i'd say it was a hit
um uh
what's it reservoir dogs i like that one
pulp fiction was okay um
this one was up there with that one
death proof i would say was
probably like uh
i'm gonna say like a number three movie
yeah right underneath i think i think
this best one was once upon a time in
hollywood and then underneath that would
have been
reservoir dogs and then this one better
you like this one better than pulp
fiction yeah yeah i think i like it
better than pulp fiction
i don't know if i do but this one is not
it's funny because i think quentin
tarantino i might have mentioned this on
wednesday but
i think um quentin tarantino has said
and wait a minute pulp fiction yeah is
it better than pulp fiction
you can't really count paul fit women no
okay it was i got him
confused yeah it's better than pull
fiction
yeah i don't agree with that i was
thinking true romance like that that was
well he just hit him directly
directed it so i'm saying it didn't
really count they just well what i was
going to say is that death proof
quentin tarantino has said that he
thinks it's his worst movie
but with the caveat that well if that's
my worst movie then i'm doing pretty
good
you know what i mean yeah i don't think
it's moving no but i'm
just saying that he thinks that he
thinks that that's his weakest movie
some of the [ __ ] that he's done is just
too [ __ ] silly for me
you know what i mean this one does have
some silly [ __ ] in it
but it's fun it's playing it's it's
paying homage to older
grindhouse type movies there's a lot of
mad max in this
you know with this car stunts everything
it looked like it looked like they were
real car stunts
that was they they were well russell
driving and everything
he said thank you again gadgy more than
welcome i look forward to the live
streams almost as much as i do popping a
wheelie at my work skate on a friday
night
man that's quite that's quite high
praise well the thing about quentin
tarantino is that you can tell that he's
you know he's really
into his old exploitation movies right
that's like this thing
and he has been on and particularly
talking about death proof he's just kind
of like i don't
he's like the last great car chase like
when this movie was you know when he was
talking about making this movie
he said was like maybe terminator 2 but
he's like i don't see the point
of doing cgi car chases like there's
nothing impressive about it
like nobody wants to see that it's like
yeah oh it's all a computer big deal
so he really did want to do something
for i mean
i think that was kind of the main um
reason that he cast
zoe bell as herself she was actually you
don't know she was actually this
uma thurman stunt woman in the kill bill
movies and
quentin tarantino was so impressed with
her uh physicality
yeah and her stunt work that he's like
i'm gonna race you into my next
movie and she didn't apparently realize
that she was kind of one of the main
characters she thought she was gonna be
like a half-assed like or like a real
small role yeah she's like the story
goes that she didn't know that it was
like such a major role until she saw her
name like on the poster like on the top
of the poster and she's like oh my god i
thought it was just like some minor
kind of [ __ ] i have to say that her
um
bryden on the [ __ ] front of that car
the ship's mask thing when you know
kurt russell's driving into the like the
side of the car and she's like [ __ ]
hanging on by the thing that's some
amazing [ __ ] right there
yeah i mean she did some amazing amazing
like stunt work on this
yeah the movie is like uh it's not a
perfect movie
but the movie does have a certain purity
to it it's
not really trying to be something that
it isn't
um i think i could have cut a good half
hour
of [ __ ] well uh
the version that's on here is the
director's cut which is
uh 27 minutes okay well there you go
then what was uh
in the theaters because i saw grindhouse
in the theater so when it came out it
was just kind of like obviously the
first half was robert rodriguez and that
was planet terror
and then there were all those fake
trailers like but i said subsequently
some of those fake trailers became real
movies like machete
and uh and uh which i had i have never
seen hobo and hobo with a shotgun i want
to see those now
um yeah there was one that was like a
thanksgiving one too that i thought was
really funny but i can't remember the
name of it
but i i can't i gotta find those because
those [ __ ] trailers were hilarious
but i love the way and so death proof
was the second one but it was a half
hour
shorter when they showed in the theater
so you know the scene where
butterfly gives kurt russell the uh the
lap dance
yeah that wasn't in the theatrical cut
you know what he did
it's like he took that part out because
i guess they thought it was too long or
whatever
and they just put like a scene missing
card in there like you know how they had
like back in the old movies where [ __ ]
would get cut out and it would say like
seen missing and they put that in there
where the where the would have been but
it's been restored now
i just said about a half hour to take
out and it's funny that that's 27
minutes but that's what yeah that's the
theatrical
yeah which is probably about right and i
bet you they cut out a lot of that
[ __ ] just
obvious obvious [ __ ] tarantino
[ __ ] foot fetish stuff i get [ __ ]
sick
there's a lot of feet of this i don't
want to see him say chicks [ __ ]
stinky ass [ __ ] feet
[Laughter]
i mean no he's turned on by that he
thinks that's real [ __ ] sexy it's
just [ __ ] feet dude
and they walk around on them and there's
[ __ ] dirt on the bottom of them
they're walking around [ __ ] barefoot
and [ __ ]
i'm not into that crap yeah okay
as far as feet goes she does have arches
she does have arched [ __ ] foot
that it is kind of a long and long
stop that [ __ ] man average woman got a
[ __ ] foot look like a damn leather
shoe
hey they're his boobies he can put
whatever he wants to in there
you can take it or leave it [ __ ] it
doesn't really bother me all that much
it's just
it's scattering me because i know what
he's thinking it's just it's funny to me
because
you know i know he's thinking it ain't
working on me
i know but i'm just saying that well he
like i said he likes that so he just
puts it in his movie yeah he's he's
trying but you know what i mean
the signal he's sending me man-to-man
through the [ __ ]
through the [ __ ] movie is look at
them delicious feet don't you like those
feet
look at those feet and i'm saying no i
don't like the feet man i don't [ __ ]
look at those feet aren't those feet
no man stop it bro i don't think he said
it's like somebody trying to [ __ ] get
you in the scat porn no man
look at that turd look at it i just it's
not that bad but
think of that you know well no don't
like that turd don't you think
how that might smell [ __ ] get the
scat off [ __ ] tv
anyway no what i was going to say though
is that i don't
know because you're you're kind of
framing it as quentin's trying to send
you signals he's trying to
i'm like no he's not sending anybody
signals he just likes that and thinks
it's
foxy and so he just puts it in his
movies because he's indulging himself
one man he's not trying to make you one
man
trying to communicate and spread his
lust for feet to another man
well kurt russell even like licks their
names he had russell bent into that [ __ ]
man
anyway i don't talk about it you know
that do you know that kressel was
actually not
i don't know if he wasn't the first
choice but they wanted there was like a
bunch of other different actors that
they were thinking about i think willem
dafoe
they asked him to do it there was a
whole bunch of different ones they asked
but none of them could do it for various
reasons
yeah um but i mean i'm really really
glad that they got [ __ ] kurt russell
to do this because
yeah he was 55 or 56 when he did this
movie yeah he's looking kind of rough
for 56 man
crusoe must have been [ __ ] hitting
the booze he looks kind of hitting
the booms again yeah i think i think
crosstalk might [ __ ] kind of
partake because uh a little too much he
got a
skin texture to me well did they kind of
rough him up for this movie though
they did i don't know because he's
supposed to be a stunt man he's stunning
mike i mean they put like the big scar
on his face
that he said he got shaving but uh so
the foot fetish thing
kind of wasn't good i think that added
you know
a little bit maybe all right yeah okay
she didn't have she i'm not gonna get
into it
you sure aren't going on a lot about
feet for somebody he doesn't like feet
the second
the second thing that he does and it's
not just
this movie it's all this [ __ ] is useless
dialogue
but he likes it his movies are very
ambling yeah and a lot of times that
doesn't bother me because
you know a lot of times i you know the
characters are interesting and [ __ ] like
that i mean once upon a time in
hollywood
it was long it was you know and it was
mostly like hanging out
but the thing is those were very
interesting characters yeah they were
recreations of
a lot of them with people who had
actually lived yeah yeah some of them
you know
see and the acting was good okay
so um you kind of believe it you feel
like you're hanging out with
some famous dude from old old timey
hollywood
you know in this one because it's
supposed to be a grind low budget
grindhouse movie
the acting is not good well it is it's
spotty it's good in some areas
in other areas but that's kind of
replicating that's kennedy's
exploitation film experience they really
nailed
it yeah so what you do is you have kind
of like novice actress
actors in there um doing this this
ambling nonsensical kind of [ __ ]
unimportant dialogue
and it's it sounds like poorly written
1970s dialogue
that's what i said i think that was i
think that was totally done but it's
something like
from an indie film you know and they
actually they didn't do it that much
it's so it's
it's kind of um he kind of was
uh accentuating it making it a little
bit too longer than it actually was in
real life from those movies of that era
yeah he made it about three times longer
than what it really was well yeah
because you have to think
we were talking about this before
exploitation movies from the 70s
a lot of times you know they were making
these movies for like a buck 98 right so
it's like they couldn't afford
to put like a whole bunch of [ __ ] in
there so it's like well we'll put like
one really gory or one really
controversial scene
and then the rest of it's just like
patted people like walking around or
talking or whatever
so it's like he really did kind of nail
that tone so that's i think that's maybe
why it didn't bother me so much is just
because
um you know that was just something that
you would have seen back then the king
of all those 70s grindhouse movies
though was mad max one
yeah okay and if you looked at that
it was had a very tight edit it didn't
have much
it didn't have much dialogue the
dialogue it did have was pretty
you know what i mean was pretty
essential to the story it wasn't a lot
of extra [ __ ]
yeah and and this movie is kind of like
that it's trying to do it with the cars
yeah but they're also throwing in
homages to other
70s movies other kind of genres other
genres
right so it the dialogue to me
felt a little bit unwieldy and i guess
it did to other people too because they
edited
27 minutes of it out which if i were to
see the theatrical cut i'd probably like
a lot better
yeah i did see the theatrical cut but i
had it but it
but you know i saw it back in 2007 it
was so long ago that when i was watching
it i didn't realize that 27 minutes have
been added back in you know what i mean
because
when i saw it i saw it as the double
feature i kind of have a feeling that
i'd like the theatrical cut better
you might yeah because i know i mean i
know for certain
that the lap dance sequence is not in
wasn't in the theatrical yeah that
really wasn't needed
not really although i guess i in a way i
kind of found it like it was fine it's a
fine scene but it's like
in a way i thought it was funnier that
they
did all this talk about the lap dance
and how she was gonna do it and then
they have seen missing
which that that to me was like much
funnier than actually showing it
yeah you know what i mean because
they're just like oh if you were waiting
to see like this girl give kurt russell
a lap dance yeah too bad
you know what i mean there wasn't
anything to it though no i know but i'm
just saying i thought
to me i thought that was funnier that
they did it like that yeah that have
actually
i think they cut it out because they
wanted your imagination to think that
there was more you know
there was more to it yeah there really
wasn't anything to it it's just like
yeah okay yawn
they tried to make it like the scene
from pulp fiction where that where what
where you know that girl was dancing for
for uh yeah yeah yeah
you know what's his name dancing for
john travolta
yeah she was dancing barefoot again yeah
come to thurman um thurman yeah
yeah it was it was supposed to be
something like that but it wasn't
it didn't quite have the same feel to it
i would say that that was handled a
little bit better in pulp fiction
but um it was still a good movie
yeah well like i said what i had
forgotten about this movie because like
i said it's been since 2007 since i saw
it i don't think i saw it again
after that is that this is essentially
it's two movies in one really i mean the
first half of the movie
is kind of more structured like a
slasher where you have like the first
group of women
and um you know then crustal is kind of
like stalking them um you know kind of
following them around to the bar and
then there's
these big long sequences where he's just
kind of like discussing stuff with
everything and then
and then you you get to the end of that
part and then he
gets rose mcgowan into his death proof
car and [ __ ] her all up and then he
goes and kills the other girl in their
car
in what i think is what is easily
the best staged car accident scene i
think i've seen in any movie i mean that
is some crazy looking [ __ ] and i think
they did a lot of that for real oh and i
should say too that this is actually
quentin tarantino's first movie that he
was the cinematographer on
so yeah okay um but yeah i mean that
[ __ ] car accident where the where
his death proof car just like smashes
into the into the women's car
and the one girl whose like leg is out
the window just goes kind of flying off
and like bouncing on the road
and like the one with the foot
and then like they go like butterfly in
the back seat like the the
you know the death proof car comes over
and like the tire just like takes off
her [ __ ] face and it's just kind of
like
it's fantastic so then it's like it's
weird because so they have that part
which is almost kind of like a movie in
itself
and then it goes to like 14 months later
and he's gone to another
uh town yeah um you know even though the
cops at this
at the scene because he kind of got hurt
in the accident too and they were just
kind of like well we think that he
killed them on purpose but we can't
prove it so he just like took off and
went to tennessee or whatever
and then he gets um starts following
that other group of women
yeah and this guy guess who's in that
[ __ ] rosario dawson
with the with the bob haircut with the
ball it looks like it's a wig she's just
cute as [ __ ]
she is cute she's probably 20 something
maybe like yeah there's the second group
who might have been in her early 30s
it's hard
how old is she now oh gosh i don't know
this is what 15 years ago
yeah she was just cute man real cute
i was like who is that girl man she
looks so familiar and i was realizing
oh that's a chick for the mandalorian
that showed up [ __ ] lizzie yeah
and she was in sin city she had a ton of
[ __ ] yeah wasn't she in some of that
sorry i thought she was in
um wasn't she in daredevil
am i thinking yeah i know i may be maybe
is she the nurse
right yeah i think he was i think she
was tila pointed out the actress who
lost the leg in that scene is the
daughter of actor sidney poitier that's
right
and her name is also sydney pointy
so i imagine that was a little confusing
she's like dad i got your mail again
but um you know what i mean uh so yeah
so the second
group of women who actually i like both
halves of this like i said the first
half is kind of more like a grimy
slasher movie
where not a lot of slashing happens it's
just kind of mostly like hanging out in
a bar
um and then at the end there's this
horrific uh you know car accident
sequence
but the second half of it which is weird
because like i said it pop
it goes ahead like 14 months and then
you don't get because for a little bit
it's in kind of black and white or like
kind of sepia tone
but then it goes into like just regular
color and it doesn't look
as all um you know aged yeah as the
first one we're getting into a problem
with this [ __ ] too
it the movie to me was looking kind of
funny i said i don't think this is right
this settings and jenny was like no
that's right i said nah
well no i was i couldn't decide a little
bit later a little bit later she goes no
i think i think we're on the wrong
settings
and i went in there and i it wasn't
motion smoothing it was uh
some kind of a some kind of a setting i
had on the television i had to put it
back to standard and all of a sudden the
movie made a lot more sense yeah it's
like it looks like you high definition
it looks too high definition
it almost looks like it we had this the
other day when we were watching
um [ __ ] man what movie we were watching
we were watching the movie the other day
we were watching ed wood yeah and i was
like why does everything look like a
cheap tv
yeah uh soap opera all of a sudden yeah
refresh rate was too high and we had to
go yeah it was like it was almost like
two
high definition so it didn't even look
like a movie anymore it looks like
it's all a cinemagraph cinemagraphic
feel to it
yeah it looked like you were sitting in
a room like watching it like i said or
watching it like on a cheap tv
that happened with that movie the
soldier
that's right i remember you watch it on
motion smoothing with too much hd it
just looks like
a live stage play on a really bad set
yeah
with the [ __ ] you're like what the
[ __ ] is this it doesn't even look like a
movie it looks like a tv program
yeah like a bat like a bad 1970s doctor
who
level yeah and i was going what the [ __ ]
is this i feel like it backed off on all
those settings and it all of a sudden it
came right back it looked beautiful
see it's just it's just a little thing
like that like makes a huge difference
so yeah if
all your [ __ ] starting to look like
cheap tv soap operas then check your tv
settings
yeah take all those settings down to
like the weakest settings
well you want like a standard setting
and i think there's a setting too on
some
uh on most tvs nowadays like because
some people want that super high
definition or
or if you're going to be watching a lot
of live sports and stuff like that where
stuff is like really fast and you want
it to be
um you know crisp and everything um but
you don't want that
setting on for movies because it looks
like ass
um but yeah so we have the we had that
happen with uh death proof when we were
first watching it because i was like i
know this is like supposed to look old
but i was like it doesn't look old it
looks
too yeah i don't know it's kind of hard
to explain like what it looked like but
it didn't look right
but then when we went in there and fixed
it it looked a lot better so because i
said it's supposed to look like a grimy
70s movie in the first uh part of it
but then in the second part it's almost
kind of like he was trying he was making
a distinction
between you know the first part which
was kind of like a slasher movie
like a 70 slasher movie it looked old
and it had like scenes missing i love
one of my favorite little touches is
that
um at the beginning of it before the
title card comes on where it says death
proof
before that it says quentin tarantino's
thunderbolt like for a second
and then it cuts off and then a little
black card that says death proof on
there
which like i said they used to retitle a
lot of those movies back then
louie says uh rosario dawson's 41 49
so that was about 15 years ago she was
about 25 26.
yeah boy time flies you'd be a young
girl one day and [ __ ] just
damn all sudden oh bat than that i'm
telling you girls man
put out let let gosh
get there guys taste some of that no
it's just gonna i don't know if that's
such good advice
listen to tom's advice
[Laughter]
live full life come here
this is this is what i have to put up
with this is what i have to put up with
all day and all night and this morning
you had to put
it yeah this morning and last night yeah
and
i can't even i can't even we went to we
went to mannequins last night
yeah and it's like i couldn't even like
eat my food he just kept like
taking pictures of my butt yeah yeah
that's just hanging out the back of that
[ __ ] i took a picture of it
i put it i didn't mean for this i forgot
that [ __ ] took that to put that [ __ ] up
on instagram i forgot that those pants
because i was like
i was just kind of like i was just kind
of like oh i forgot i have these pants
and then i was like oh the reason that i
put them away and didn't wear them was
because every time you walk they kind of
like slide down because they're a little
bit too big
and uh and they don't you know they
don't they don't junk you didn't care
though
that's true well i just got sick of like
tugging on them because like i said i
had uh
fake nails on so it was hard for me to
like keep tugging my pants up so after
all i was just like [ __ ] it as long as
my like ass crackers that's how
chicken or twenties would have wore that
[ __ ] just yeah if i could come down
yeah but i'm an old bat that's great and
you're mine i can't get away with that i
said you might yeah you can
taylor says poor jenny
that's the worst will was looking he's
like yeah
yeah he had his uh his girlfriend is um
she's in the army reserves right yeah
he's streaming her and he was
and he streams her when he goes out yeah
she's like with him so she can go too
she's watching this because she's at the
barracks or whatever and he can't like
go out so he's just so he like brings
her along
like i think that's so funny that he
does that
and he's like talking to her the whole
time because we went to we all three of
us went to chantal's after and got
something i got a picture i got a
catfish
i got a video of that but uh yeah i
think unless i threw it out
well what yeah i think well you deleted
it because i he told me we were outside
out we were i got it still oh okay we
were out front
like take a video of me and i was like
man you look super drunk it's yeah i'm
literally
so funny and will's with me
we're out in the middle of the [ __ ]
street and i can barely [ __ ] look
i can hold on and turn the volume up so
you guys can hear what we're saying
i don't even remember where you're
saying i don't remember i probably
wouldn't say
anything
like a little
[Laughter]
yeah it's coming down it wasn't that bad
yet
yeah see that's his girlfriend
[Laughter]
yeah that was that was last night we had
a good time though
man we did yeah yeah it wasn't uh
they had a street party going on there
for a while and then they cleared them
out just till 11.
left so yeah then we went to chantals
talking to the guy about movies trying
to get him to see willie's wonderland
yeah yeah the dj from over there yeah
we were talking about candy i should
have recorded that i know that was funny
yeah yeah we were all like
we were all talking about horror movies
yeah i had
mostly sobered up by that point but it's
just kind of like yeah because he
he had seen um i don't even remember how
he got started talking about that but he
was talking about how scared he was of
uh animatronics
yeah and so we were talking about
theater in wonderland wonderland
yeah we were trying to do that i was
gonna actually say something about
something else about death proof what
was it um oh you know what
okay and i get maybe i'm remembering
this wrong
but i thought that when i saw death
proof in the theater
i thought that there was another scene
because i'm spoiler alert but the very
last scene
um you know because he starts chasing
the second group of women
but the second group of women two of
them are stunt people and the other two
are kind of like so they're
like not having it and uh so they
kind of you know they kind of the cat
and mouse game gets like reversed you
know so they start chasing him
and at the very end they do like a very
faster pussycat
kill kill thing where they're just kind
of like roundhouse just like punching
his ass out and then like rosario
dawson like caves his head in with her
boot
and i could have sworn that
there was another scene after that where
they went back
to that farm with the [ __ ] up dodge
challenger
to get their friend because they left
the friend in the cheerleader outfit
uh played by mary elizabeth winstead
actually um
they left her at the farm with the with
the creepy weirdo yeah
and i thought that there was another
scene i could have sworn that there was
another scene after that where they went
back and got her and she had like killed
that guy
i must have been because he was like
trying to pause maybe that was only in
the uh
maybe that was only in the uh theatrical
theatrical
or maybe i just it was a fever dream and
i just like totally
or maybe you know what maybe what it was
was that when i first saw the movie
and i was just kind of like what
happened to that other girl then they
they like
threw under the bus and they left her
with this like creepy cletus like back
in this [ __ ] farm
what happens now when they bring his
[ __ ] car back and it's all [ __ ]
trash
she gotta pay for it with that ass well
that we'll see that was the implication
so i was just kind of like yeah some
friends you guys
are yeah well hey babe stay here we're
gonna go as collateral like
why don't we take this car it was
supposed to be a 70s groundhouse movie
that was transit you weren't supposed to
think about [ __ ] like that people
vanished in those movies all the time
that's true oh well we got to go and
then you know what happened to that
character we don't know what happened to
that care it didn't matter
that way it wasn't okay we're gonna get
some we're gonna go up the store
bye where'd dad go i don't know
that's just like so funny to me yeah
they didn't really
i guess a lot of those movies weren't
really uh thought through
all that all that well she said she
didn't remember that scene
that's that's the thing maybe i just
imagined it maybe i just like wrote it
in my head because i was like i wonder
whatever happened to that girl
like when they went back and they took
the [ __ ] up car and yeah because she
was just kind of like looking at him
like oh [ __ ]
like what did you girls get me into
because they just wanted to go out and
play ship's mask man they didn't care
about leaving her a little ass there
yep but i could but [ __ ] man i could
have sworn i could have sworn there was
you're reading too much into it no i'm
just saying that i thought that i
thought that there was the scene where
they came back and she had killed that
guy or tied him up or something like
that but it's like maybe i'm just
leaving her there and not
not answering what had happened would
have been tarantino's way of saying ah
[ __ ] it
70s we don't get seven and the weird
another thing is is that the
this is not taking place in the 70s no
it's not it's a lot of 70s stuff in it
but if you look in the background man
there's modern cars driving around and
you know
they don't really show yeah they had
like nokia phones and stuff yeah
so you know it's it's not um [ __ ] man my
thing phillip
it's it's not your thing fell off no
that's you know
about the little pad for my glasses oh i
was going to say yeah you better kiss it
because if people are just if people are
just listening to the audio podcast and
then
like his thing fell off yeah these these
are aftermarket ones i got off the
[ __ ]
off of uh amazon and you they plug in
but they'll also come right back out
you know it's a little bro yeah they're
not
they're not the best ones i need to get
some other ones well you know as long as
you can kind of see i mean i just buy
these [ __ ] things at
walgreens although honestly i think i
got these ones
on amazon it was like a five pack for
like 10 bucks or something
and i lose them all the time all in all
i think this is one of tarantino's
better movies he thinks it's his worst
one i think he's tripping
uh his tastes are a little really not to
my taste
you know like in glorious bastards i
thought that she was [ __ ] silly they
killed bill 1-2 i just thought that [ __ ]
was really silly
oh i liked the kill bill movies i saw
the i saw those in the theater as well
i didn't like them did you well some of
them um i was like i had i
haven't seen uh django unchained yet and
i haven't seen
no i did see the hateful eight i liked
that one yeah i hate the way it was okay
i liked hatefully that's pretty good
it's kind of like a western version of
[ __ ] reservoir dogs in a certain way
yeah that could have also been a play i
mean he definitely has his
proclivities well like i said you know
all filmmakers do i guess yeah
he has his things that i forgot about
the hate blade i need to watch that one
again
yeah i watched it i think it was on el
rey network like maybe a year or
something ago when i watched it and i
remember
like because i remember the first time i
watched it it didn't really make much of
an impression but i think the second
time i watched it i liked it much better
because i was paying more attention to
it i guess still gotta say that
to this day his best once is still um
[ __ ] once upon a time in hollywood i
like it i loved that i liked the tone of
that movie
the writing uh he didn't it had a lot of
dialogue on it but it wasn't used
useless chatter
it was like it was high quality dialogue
i liked it it was just good
and he's [ __ ] with you you know that
this is about the sharon tate murders
and you know
you they're voting they already showed
the family
and you know the and then they never did
show um
um what's in charles manson did they
they never showed him yeah they showed
him come out of that house
well he went up to the house yeah they
showed him coming out of the house like
looking for cause remember remember i
said he had gone to that house before
like looking for that guy that used to
live there
but i don't remember them i don't
remember them ever showing him
at the ranch i think he was out of town
wasn't he it wasn't just squeaky didn't
doing all of it
mostly he was well he charles manson was
in it a little bit
yeah he only walking out of sharon
tate's house
yeah and that was that's the only time
you see him
he he talks a little bit yeah maybe no
no [ __ ] now i'm gonna have to remember
him yeah he talks a little bit
sworn he was at this point he goes up
and talks to him and then hey how you
doing and he's like oh nice guy and then
he leaves i don't think they ever show
him at the ranch
maybe they didn't i think i think they
said he was out of town or something
he's had of town on a business trip look
at charles manson he might have been
hiding out
yes i don't remember them because it was
the girl that was running everything
yeah that's true and you know he
it wasn't the night of the murder that
what's
that the stunt man ended up at the ranch
yeah it was before
and and i i don't think i don't think he
was there
because remember that i think it was i
think wasn't it squeaky
one that was looking out the window
calling all the shots i think so yeah
that was about it it's a good movie
though louis says jackie brown is one of
my favorite movies i haven't seen that
in years and years i i saw it and it was
really good but i
really need to see it again because it's
been such a long time yeah that's one of
his might be good
yeah well it's interesting because it
seems like jackie brown
and death proof or grindhouse were the
two of his movies that did
uh the least amount of business and
interestingly because they were both
based on exploitation films
you know what i mean because jackie
brown was kind of like his homage to
like black playstation movies
um and death proof was kind of his
homage to slasher movies you know
car like muscle car movies [ __ ] like
that like from the 70s
and i don't know i just think that's
really interesting that
he made two movies like homaging that
particular genre and those were the ones
that
did the least amount of business maybe
people don't want to see that
but to me i mean i don't know if anybody
that knows me like knows how much i love
when i love like when when the medium
like fits thematically in with whatever
it is that you're doing
so i really really love the fact that
him and robert rodriguez said we're
gonna make
we're gonna do like an experience that's
just like
if you went to a grindhouse theater in
the 70s and saw a double feature and all
these [ __ ] trailers
and then they took all of that time to
make it look
like it came out back then and they made
went to all the trouble to make all the
fake trailers they aged the [ __ ]
they like i said they had funny little
uh you know details like the title card
switch out like the scene missing kind
of [ __ ]
like sometimes the audio went out of
sync like all this other you know the
color would [ __ ] up for a second
and it's just like it was just such a
great i don't know i just really really
liked the whole
and the fact that they went that far to
like fit in with the theme i just i love
that
yeah i mean i i liked it just because it
had it did have that 70s tone
uh car murder type thing like death race
2000 and mad max yeah tila i think just
mentioned death ratio 2000 yeah kind of
had it kind of had
that and they even mentioned some other
movies from that genre like gone in 60
seconds and
it was you know so yeah
kind of had an all-american motif to the
to it
um even though mad max wasn't an
american movie
still part of the american zeitgeist at
that time you know
that was actually one of the better that
was like one of the best ones
and it wasn't even american but um
the only thing was wrong with mad max
and [ __ ] beyond and
and uh and what was it mad max ii
what'd they call it road warrior yeah
they were [ __ ] dubbed
for some stupid-ass reason see i just
i'm against dubbing yeah i'll give it a
pass in giallo movies okay
but because that's just what they did
but other than that
just knock it off knock it off first
time i saw mad max in the original
australian dot in the original
australian dub i was like oh yeah
okay see it so much better yeah the
movie became so much more upscale
i mean that's how it should have been
released in the us
and and that movie would have gone a lot
further with the original australian dub
because the american dub [ __ ] sucked
it's
most dubs suck it i don't think i've
ever seen terrible i don't think i've
ever seen a good
and they did that they did that [ __ ]
because the [ __ ] studios and
contractual
[ __ ] you know oh well if it's going to
be important in here then that means we
got to work on it
you know we want our cut too well they
didn't want audiences thinking it was
foreign i think is kind of what it is uh
looking back on what they were saying in
the movies they did that to
i think that was [ __ ] i think that
was a lie
that they would tell people so they
could get work
doing voice acting work on it and put
their stint so the studios could put
their stamp on it and make their [ __ ]
money
that's all it was that's what i that's
what i think they didn't want to release
it in its original form
i mean because they couldn't they
couldn't get any money out of that
you know what i'm talking about the
thing about it is that i mean if you
can't understand like if the movie's
british or australian or whatever and i
know like some americans are like oh i
can't understand you know the accents
well just turn the [ __ ] uh you know
turn the closed captioning on that's
what i do because i'm [ __ ] deaf
yeah i can understand a chinese movie
you're gonna want to dub it
you know i don't even like that i would
rather read the subtitles
it sucked too but those were basically
for kids yeah so
it didn't matter uh but with something
like an australian movie
oh man max made a lot more sense in like
they're speaking english
that's not what i meant though what i
meant was is that
it's when they put an american dub in it
they're trying to what
fool the audience into thinking that
this is somewhere in the united states
well yeah that's what i'm saying is
you're driving on that yeah drivers on
the other side of the world
merle why are they out there yeah you
know and
where is this you know what you know
never seen a town like that where is
that oklahoma
you don't know it made a lot more sense
when you had that australian flair to it
and then you go oh of course this isn't
happening here this is happening in
another country
and it landed down under yeah and then
all of a sudden it just
the it you let the movie have its damn
identity
you know yeah it had an ethnic identity
and that's and it made a lot more sense
with the
with its ethnic identity in place well
what was that one movie that we did was
i think it was uh might have been a
chinese movie yeah was that like that
sci-fi movie
and remember we first started watching
it and it was dubbed into english and
we're like this is really not that good
but then when we switched over to
the original movie yeah yeah yeah that
was a good movie
and then yeah it was like i was like oh
it's like immediately like 200 percent
better
because you're actually hearing the
people's actual voices
what was the name of that movie second
earth or something earth 2 or
god damn it wandering earth wandering
earth i think it was the wandering earth
right
because it wasn't the whole time wasn't
all premise of the movie that the earth
was like wandering around and it was
like getting super cold or whatever
yeah the earth i think it was called the
wandering the earth had been thrown out
of its orbit
yeah that's right and it was all freeze
and solid i just remember
how stark the difference was because we
first started watching it because it
came up automatically with the english
dub
and we were watching it i was like this
isn't really that good it's like is it
do we really have to watch it like
dubbed in english because i can't stand
that
i just thought that was the way that
they were presenting it because
for whatever reason i don't know if
there's some setting you can change
probably on that one
and then but we just it immediately got
away yeah it looked real upscale once
you put it in chinese
and um it felt a lot better and i don't
remember exactly what happened
were they going to steer the earth they
were going to steer the planet towards
another
planet or were they going to leave on
ships i forgot i think
yeah something like that they're going
to live underground or
something i can't remember exactly how
yeah i think some of them were living
underground but then some of them had
plans to
yeah it's been a while since we've seen
it yeah and tila said what they did with
the movie marianne on netflix yeah that
dubbing was horrible that's what i said
yeah see that's what i thought too it's
like
i don't you know i i don't mind them
having the option like if you want to
watch the english dub
um but i've very rarely
seen anything where that was like a good
thing you know i just
if you want to have it as an option
that's fine if people don't want to read
subtitles
i get it but it's just i don't know it
just it throws me out of the movie too
much
like i said i give an exception for
jealous movies because i'm just like
that's just part of the whole
genre at this point for me just like the
bad dubbing
but um you know t said that uh
tarantino's one of the best directors of
all times um i
i'm gonna i'm gonna look at it this way
he's a notable director you can tell
it's his movie you can tell yeah
he has a very distinctive style and it's
kind of like
tarantino is a brand it's you know what
i mean
he's like a brand name uh he's almost a
character in the movies that he
he usually is a character in the movies
that he's directing well he was in he
was in death proof he played like the
bartender or the bar manager or whatever
but also him as a director
is a character you can feel him direct
in that movie
yeah you know but like i said there's a
lot to be said for that and another
thing too is like you know say what you
want about tarantino and some people
have said oh you know he's just a hack
or he's just like makes homages to other
genres but the thing about it is that
he's almost as far as i know he's like
pretty self-taught right
yeah it's just like he got his whole
film making education
from working in a video store and
watching [ __ ] tons of movies and you can
tell
every single movie he makes you can tell
he [ __ ] loves
making movies he is super super
enthusiastic about it he talked his way
into those studios
yeah you know he was the kid that worked
up in the
up in the damn via you know the video
store
right there next to [ __ ]
elementary school where we went to
elementary school you know
dominguez elementary you know
i left but my friends who stayed there
knew it you know they'd go and rent
videos from him he was just that dude
yeah yeah crazy kimmy went to school
with yeah the crazy kid he was like
super super into movies yeah he's real
nerdy kind of ass burglary
and he started hanging out with movie
people because he could speak that
lingo knew everything about it and he
talked his way into those studios
and like i said there's a lot to be
admired for yeah is he a hack
yeah yeah he's a hack director but he's
a [ __ ] great one
he he made that a style
you know what i mean because he liked
those kind of movies he said i'ma take
this hack direct director stuff and all
this grind house [ __ ] i'm gonna make
that my style
and elevate it in the way that a [ __ ]
good chef would
take a [ __ ] ox tail and elevate that
into into
that's actually yeah that's actually a
good metaphor because that's what he's
doing
and another thing that i think is great
is that a lot of times
he will bring to light uh some genres or
some films that have been forgotten
about
yeah and he'll kind of bring them to the
public and make them popular again which
i think is really awesome
yeah is he a kubrick no no he's not
that's not real it's it's important to
compare them they're too completely
different different style very different
kubrick was about total immersion you
know
he was gonna bring you a hit a reality
you know he was good every aspect of it
was well thought out nothing really left
a chance
in pretty much every kubrick movie i've
seen is like that nothing was left to
change they're very controlled yeah
yeah whereas they're they're both great
they're both very different
tarantinos are just very much more like
loose and like
ramshackle it's about style and spirit
yeah and like i said
i love the fact that he's just so
[ __ ] enthusiastic
about making movies about the movies
that he loves and he's like
and the fact that he's like oh i love
exploitation movie so much i love kung
fu movies so much i want to make one
like that
right but in my own [ __ ] style it's
like you know that's awesome
yeah well you could say his success that
he's great because uh you know who is
who he is most directors you don't know
their names most directors it's kind of
a generic product
in a big old [ __ ] system that just
pumps out a lot of crap every year
um he made a lot of money and he'll be
remembered
yeah i mean like i said if you're gonna
make movies like like put his [ __ ]
stamp on it
yeah make sure that you know from the
first frame everybody said whoop
that's that guy's movie or that girl's
movie you know his style you can feel it
when you see it so how could how could
he be bad
yeah exactly how could you say that he
failed no he didn't fail
and tila makes the point it's like i
don't like all his stuff but i don't
like all of hitchcock either exactly
it's like not everybody you know knocks
it out of the park every time even
geniuses
you know there there are a couple of
tarantino movies that i wasn't
wild about i've mostly liked most of
them but
um you know it's like i said he's not my
favorite i'm more like into kubrick and
david lynch and stuff like that
but um i'm pretty much always like
watching new tarantino liquid yeah you
know lynch is a master and i don't
really like
his movies that much but he but some
people just [ __ ] love that [ __ ] i see
the quality
yeah i love that [ __ ] i'm one of those
people that's like totally obsessive
about it do you know what i mean
[Laughter]
i'm more into you know [ __ ] like uh
oh [ __ ] good carpenter was really good
not [ __ ] carpenter
some of that carpenter he didn't do i
think he had other people directing
the directors have half-lifes uh but
cronenberg good cronenberg his son
is good yeah i was that um
tomorrow i gotta record i watched uh
anti-viral like brandon cronenberg's
first
random movie and uh yeah i'm gonna
record a review of that tomorrow or
tuesday and yeah that'll be going up in
a couple weeks
but um yeah because we did possess her
right yeah
anti-viral was pretty [ __ ] up too i
gotta say yeah
those are all good weird diseases he's
kind of walking in his dad's footsteps
it does feel a little elevated
yeah a little higher budget it's not
it's just that the equipment is
is now available yeah yeah you can do
something different i mean they
definitely
they definitely have the same uh you
know the same thing
yeah which like i said it's not
surprising because it's possible why
that's what
brandon cronenberg's fans are gonna be
looking for that
yeah they're gonna be wanting cronenberg
[ __ ] so he's carried on a fan
a family tradition i mean it would be
weird if like david kronenberg's son
came out and started making like cheesy
romantic comedies yeah
although how awesome stuff how awesome
would it be like to see it
to see a rom-com director
it would be so messed up trying to think
of what you know
what else about cronenberg that made it
made him memorable
everything was like on in kind of eerie
locations even if they were mundane
it had an eerie feel to it uh part of it
i think was because
certain things were kind of cheap uh
because the technology wasn't there but
in some ways that kind of enhanced it
it's like you're looking at a crime
scene photo
or something yeah well and and i think
it's the same thing where
you know we're talking about directors
having proclivities like you know
quentin tarantino with his exploitation
films and his feet and stuff like that
the cronenbergs are definitely one body
horror obviously
uh two uh corporate espionage uh
clinical setting corporate stuff yeah
that's where the bad shits happen in any
way but that's
like a lot of their movies now david
croninberg's later movies like eastern
promises and stuff like that went more
in like
almost like a crime thriller direction
they're also very good but they
and they're you know have gory parts in
them but they kind of went away from
body horror type of stuff um cronenberg
man
videodrome disturbing probably one of
his best i think it might be his best
one but for me personally there's just
something about the brood
that just so many go to the brew dead
ringers oh my god like so many good ones
i'm going to say the brute for me
i think because i was younger when i saw
it was young when i saw it
and the idea of them damn weird demented
[ __ ] babies and [ __ ]
her with that the babies
locations that looked like california
with the slanted woodworking you know
yeah
the wood paneling was slanted like that
it was like old
uh universities looked like that and
training institutes and
little corporate places you know what i
mean where they would you know like rent
to have
[ __ ] uh meetings and yeah
look like that you know and we would see
them out in california so i could kind
of just
it seemed familiar to me as a little kid
like those locations so it's like
oh yeah you could be anywhere in these
little babies in little foodie pajamas
and [ __ ] tag you and [ __ ]
had weird faces you know what i mean
they were all kind of like
they were drones they weren't male or
female and they were kind of like an ant
colony
and kind of down syndrome-y looking and
just
man it was a [ __ ] that was a scary
movie when you were a kid it was pretty
because it was made for
adults yeah but you know [ __ ] we watched
everything man
and uh man you didn't want to run into
them little kids
they were about the same size as me back
then yeah yeah it [ __ ] scared me and
manga said let's not forget the fly
easily one of the best remakes of all
time for sure yeah i was growing by the
time the fly came out though that was 86
when i
yeah it didn't it didn't impact me very
much man i love that more like
the brood and [ __ ] the thing
and [ __ ] video drum and
[ __ ] oh man was knight breed
cronenberg he was in it but i don't know
if he directed yeah i don't think he
directed that did he but he was in it
too once he played the like the bad guy
um tila said uh ari astor is really good
right now i agree uh he did mid-summer
and
hereditary i also like ty west but he's
so unknown i liked uh i really really
liked house of the devil
i think i've seen a couple of other thai
west movies so let somebody remind me
what they are
but i remember house of the devil being
really good and i watched that not too
long ago
um yeah that was clyde barker that's
what i thought
yeah clyde barker did not breed that was
from his story i just didn't know if he
had directed it because i knew he had
directed some of his own [ __ ]
clyde barker was real interesting when
he first appeared i got sick of him
though
well clive barker is another guy that
kind of has his things
he gets his things and he did it yeah
but you know everybody does
i think he did raw head wrecks she did
yeah yeah and we liked it when it came
i really wish somebody would remake that
but good right
that's what we were thinking because
it's such a good idea right
it's such a good idea for a story well
you know it's it's it's taki
we were watching it in michigan where
you know
basically irish american descendants of
irish americans or whatever and so
it's talking about back in the honky
motherland these monsters
and we could identify with it you know
and
it did have enough to get you interested
in the church with the [ __ ] stained
glass windows and the glowing eyes and
the secret room that ended somewhere
else and a [ __ ]
catholic priest that was secretly a
worshiper of [ __ ] raw head wrecks
and [ __ ] and then he comes out of the
damn ground
and baptizes the priest by pissing on
him he's going yeah it's my lord
[Laughter]
we're like what the [ __ ] is this the
only problem
really it would have been the problem
with raw head wrecks
was the eyes on the [ __ ] monster yeah
they were like googly
big old googly eyes it didn't blink and
they didn't move so it was not
animatronic enough
had it been something maybe a little bit
closer to pumpkin head
it would have been a lot better yeah i
mean that movie like i said it's such
it's a great idea it was just badly
executed that's all i mean it's
it's entertaining because it's kind of
awful
but it's such a it's just i don't know
it that seems like something that needs
like a real disturbing
it needs a remake it needs a really good
remake where the action scenes of that
of [ __ ] raw head tearing through them
damn trailers and [ __ ] killing them
trailer park people in in the hockey
motherland and even better
fourth drawdown says the monster looked
like i built it yeah yeah
that was the problem yeah it wasn't that
good
but you know we were there i was there
at the time hanging out with my friends
at the time
we were very forgiving of these movies
well yeah
we did not look at them with a critical
eye like
people do today we knew that there were
movies we knew that they were cheap
movies
we laughed at [ __ ] like that but it
didn't mean we didn't like it or we
didn't or that we
rejected it we were like yeah that was a
good show well that's what i mean i
i mean i have if i say a movie's bad
that doesn't mean that i didn't like it
it's just i have a lot of affection for
bad movies because i kind of admire
anybody that can get a movie made
because it's kind of
a kid's kind of a pain in the ass
anybody that can do it and then they
kind of fail
i'm just kind of like well you know you
tried it and like i said as long as the
movie entertains me
then it's not bad yeah you know what i'm
saying it needs a remake
it does that really seems like i you
know what hulu did a series
called books of blood it was like a mini
series um that was based on some of
clyde barker's short stories and it was
it wasn't bad it was pretty it had a
really good idea
yeah really good ideas not exactly the
monster was not executed well
the murders that it committed weren't
executed very well uh it's just they
didn't have the money
i mean clive barker he is so good at
world building and coming up with these
just [ __ ]
crazy like this crazy imagery and it's
really really hard
you know it's easy to do in a book but
it's really really hard to do it
in a movie that doesn't look stupid i
mean i would love to see a movie of
weave world that would be fantastic they
could they could do it nowadays with um
you know with cgi and stuff but i just
feel like a lot of his [ __ ] doesn't get
across because his stuff is so complex
what i would have done now with rawhead
first of all he'd look badass
all right he'd have been a totally
believable looking [ __ ] demonic
warlord okay and he would have come out
he would have been
he would have had the ability to raise a
whole army
of followers yeah that would have made a
lot more sense
that he was going to reclaim his kingdom
and that that kingdom was going to
damn take over the world so you have to
figure out how this is gonna happen
people joining up and then people coming
from the bowels of hell to fight this
too
so you have to have like the armies of
like undead
or some or something like that yeah i
mean if you're going to do a clive
barker you can't cheap out
no because his stuff is tends to be epic
yeah it has to be some epic thing you
know
and basically you know the armies of the
world are going to have to try to stop
this [ __ ] thing before it gets too
big
yeah that's what you have to that it
can't just be like some sort of pig
looking
just dude just knocking some knocking
stuff down he's got chains on him
yeah i used to be a warlord but now this
dude is going to tear your trailer
[ __ ] your airstream yeah
yeah yeah there that's not gonna do
enough world concord
yeah no you're gonna have to have demon
horses demons yeah you need the whole
you need to go home you need people
joining up you know living people
[ __ ]
you know what i mean i pledge an
allegiance to these things it would have
to be it's like something out of lord of
the rings
yeah you know that's what i mean his
stuff is just very very lord of the
rings meets the modern world that's how
you do it
tila also points out guillermo del toro
is great too i also agree with that
pan's labyrinth is awesome i love pan's
labyrinth i love
the devil's backbone um he made one
called oh [ __ ] what was the name of it
uh chronos
that might have been his first one
that's actually really good as well it's
sort of like a vampire movie but not
quite you know what i mean that was also
really good but yeah i've liked all of
his [ __ ]
i really really wanted to see his take
on uh at the mountains of madness but i
guess that's never gonna happen
what i would like also and i've been
saying this for years is i would like a
true
remake of the omega man
not you know what i'm talking about yeah
the charlton heston omega man with you
know what i mean with the uh with the
mutants and everything
the talking vampires yeah i'd like a
remake of that and a pandemic because
you know you have the whole pandemic
theme and everything and
that would be really cool but it has to
be done right
i still wish that somebody would make a
faithful adaptation of
the act of the book you know what i mean
yeah
i guess the last man i wrote was last
man on earth was actually pretty good
was
that was the closest one of the three
that they've made it needs we need a
remake of charlton heston's a mega man
yeah they could do that yeah like i said
i'm not completely averse to remakes
especially
if one had a lot of potential or it was
a great idea but it was poorly executed
um and they could do it a lot better
nowadays yeah because there's a lot of
[ __ ] we could do better nowadays
yeah you could do a mega man really well
now yeah you
you know now that we have cgi like i
said i feel like they could do more
[ __ ] with like you know clive barker and
stuff like that so you could
empty cities dudes dudes trying
he's the last of his kind he's a human
he's in a world of these damn mutants
who are basically vampires they're
albino psychotic vampires they're
hunting you down like you're the last
relic of a [ __ ] forgotten a era they
don't have technology but you do because
they can't use technologies against
their religion
so you just one dude with so he's
against these masses of people
but it's offset because he has machine
guns flame throwers and
lives in a damn castle that's a great
idea you could do that now
yeah yeah although the thing about it
though is i do kind of feel like in the
last
few years because you remember how for a
while like in the
maybe like the mid 90s to the mid 2000s
it's like everything was [ __ ] zombie
movies and it's like everyone's got
[ __ ] sick of zombie movies
i kind of feel like now it's kind of
like similar to zombie movies more like
you know
parasite movies or you know uh you know
pandemic type movies are just like
everywhere yeah taylor tila's never seen
omega man
oh you'll love a mega man it's late 60s
early 70s charlton heston
he's the last man on earth uh everybody
gets white
got wiped out in a pandemic yeah it's
based on i am legend
but yeah everybody got wiped out in a
pandemic except these mutants he's the
last human
these mutants are basically vampires in
the in the original story they were
vampires
and they see him as the monster yeah
all right so they're trying to kill him
it's a reverse role reversal
and in it's played by charlton heston
his name is colonel neville
and it turns out he made that bio weapon
that everybody died from in the pandemic
and he had the cure
he was trying to deliver it at the time
it got out
so he's responsible for the death of
[ __ ] mankind and he lives in his
second castle
can you imagine in l.a running around
l.a and they show la and it's totally
vacant
and they come out at night and they're
trying to hunt him he's got [ __ ]
machine
machine guns and [ __ ] night vision
scopes and
they're hunting them down it's a great
movie it's campy in the 70s way but
it's it's really cool really cool yeah i
like it you got to see omega man
and it's like i said it's based on i am
legend but it
kind of you know i want to say is it
loosely based
i don't know if i'd go so far say it's
loosely based they did change some [ __ ]
they changed some stuff yeah but
not that much i still think the last man
on earth with vincent price is the
closest to the book
but i don't think there's actually been
a true adaptation of the book ever all
of them have changed yeah
loses man becomes the legend that's
right yeah matter of fact there's a uh
rob zombie has a song from in on the
band called
white zombie called i am legend
or i am legend and it's about the movie
omega man i am legend and the last man
on earth
all combined into the same song yeah
uh it's it's on white zombies uh first
album
it's a good song it's a real good song
tila's hubby says isn't the will smith
movie a remake yeah well yeah
essentially it's not really a remake of
the omega man as so much as it's another
adaptation of the richard matheson novel
but the will smith one is the worst of
all in the world easily
and they [ __ ] i mean the end [ __ ] up
negates the whole point of the [ __ ]
story which pisses me off there's a
couple problems with the
uh with the eye with will smith version
one it's only in an isolated area it's
like in one city
it was the entire world yeah he was the
last man
on earth yeah so just taking that
element
out of the [ __ ] story [ __ ] the story
up
all right another thing is is that the
my understanding is that the original
cut of the movie was a lot better but
they
cut a lot of stuff out and um
uh to shorten it and it kind of dumbed
that movie down a lot the will smith
version so
i've heard there's an extended cut
that's a lot better another thing that
was
wrong about it is that the mutants
in the in the will smith version didn't
talk which there there goes your story
because
it's just kind of like a straight-up
zombie story that's something we have a
ton of
zombie movies already we didn't you know
yeah in
in the omega man
the mutants are some of the the most
important characters because they talk
yeah and they have their own backstory
of who they were well in their own
culture and
their whole thing they have a whole
religion and everything and and they're
they're they're uh alba if you got hit
with it
most people died some people were
mutated
into albinos you turned you became into
an albino you could only come out at
night
but it also made you a raging [ __ ]
psychopath
a lunatic and uh but they were all had
normal
intelligence and they had a religion
of where the old ways were evil okay and
the old people were evil they're
god's new creations and it was their job
to go around
and burn down all the libraries and
destroy all the technology of the old
because that's what led to
that's what led to the pandemic yeah and
there's one dude left neville they don't
they're not really sure who he is
there's one dude left and they're
dedicated
to killing this dude but they can't use
technology because that would admit
they'd be admitting that technology was
good they were going to do it without
technology catapults and [ __ ] like that
catapults knives and spears and there's
one dude living up in a damn castle
that's fully fortified it's got power
and everything so he stands for
everything that they hate
and he's a legend they see him as a
monster because all he does go around
and killing them all
while they're sleeping like it was
vampire yeah like they were vampires
but he's but to them he's the monster
because he goes around killing them
he's catching them and trying to do
experiments on them and turn them back
into humans and [ __ ] it's
oh man you want to see omega man tonight
yes you'll like it's an old movie but
it's real well done well and i recommend
the book too like
seriously read i am legend yeah the
class yeah and i am legend they're not
mutants they're they're they're vampires
essentially yeah they're vampires and in
the original book they're vampires in
in the omega man they're mutants but
it's the same it's pretty much the same
idea
it's just it's a distinction without a
difference really right um
all right so we've been going for almost
an hour and a half holy crap
we have anything else to say about
quentin tarantino about any other
directors
about anything else tila said to her i
think we saw that
i can't remember which is a bad sign
[Laughter]
yeah i i didn't love it yeah
she said yeah time so i also added the
book to the booklet
yeah the book is really good i mean i
love richard mouth now there's a vincent
price version and in black and white
that's close to that book
yeah it's called i think it came out in
1958
yeah i liked that as well that's the
closest adaptation they did change some
[ __ ]
but that's the closest to the book yeah
that one's they're they're vampires
slash
zombie and he's the last guy he's the
last one yeah and i mean anything with
bit surprise yeah
i'll watch anything with vincent price
in it you know but that's a good movie
all right so uh you ready to wrap it up
all right so
we will be back tomorrow probably do a
movie review tomorrow we'll either
we'll either do buggy nights or
brimstone and trickle depending on what
we
feel like watching later on um but yeah
we'll come back and talk about that
tomorrow
and then we'll probably do a food show
on tuesday and uh that's how that's
gonna go over the next couple days
so have a good rest of your weekend and
we will talk to you guys again tomorrow
bye